tomás dejo dos paquetes para enviar un
paquete peso 1.38 kilogramos y el otro
paquete peso 720 gramos cuál es el peso
combinado de ambos paquetes en gramos
así que el primer peso no los dan en
kilogramos y el otro peso no nos dan en
gramos cuál es el peso combinado de
ambos paquetes en gramos lo que tenemos
que hacer aquí es tener ambos pesos en
gramos para después sumarlos y tener el
peso combinado vemos que el peso del
segundo paquete ya está en gramos pesa
720 gramos así que tenemos que convertir
el peso del primer paquete de kilogramos
a gramos así que queremos conocer cuánto
es 1.38 kilogramos que podemos abreviar
así y nos dicen que un kilogramo es
igual a 1000 gramos y esto es lo que
significa este prefijo de kilo
mil así que para pasar de 1 a 1.38 pues
tenemos que multiplicar esto por 1 punto
38 así
en este lado de los gramos vamos a tomar
esta cantidad y también la vamos a
multiplicar por 1 punto 38 así que
tenemos 1000 x 1.38 va a ser igual a mil
380 gramos que abre veamos así ahora
vamos a sumar el peso de ambos paquetes
este es el peso del primer paquete en
gramos y vamos a sumarle el peso del
segundo paquete 720 gramos lo sumamos 0
+0 08 más 12 es 10 llevo 17 más 13 10
más una que llevo es 11 1 más 1 es 2 y
nos queda que el peso total es de 2.100
gramos hagamos otro problema de
conversión de unidades
julia y sus amigos están haciendo
cometas de papel para cada cometa se
necesita un pedazo de papel que tiene
puntos 65 metros de ancho cuántos
centímetros de papel se necesitan para
hacer cuatro cometas aquí nos están
diciendo el ancho del papel en metros
pero quieren después
en centímetros y además la respuesta
para cuatro cometas pensemos en esto
cada cometa mide 0.65 metros así que
para pasar de 1.65 pues multiplico esto
por punto 65 y ahora del lado de los
centímetros
voy a multiplicar estos 100 centímetros
también por punto 65 y así obtendré la
cantidad en centímetros del ancho del
papel de cada cometa bueno 65 centenas
por 100 va a ser igual a 65 centímetros
y esto es para cada una de las cometas
así que el ancho de una cometa en
centímetros es 65 centímetros pero no
nos están preguntando cuál es la medida
en centímetros para hacer una cometa
sino que nos preguntan los centímetros
de papel que se necesitan para hacer
cuatro cometas así que vamos a
multiplicar esto por 4 4 por 5 es 20
llevo 24 por 6 20
42 26 nos quedan 260 centímetros es la
cantidad necesaria de papel para hacer
cuatro cometas hagamos otro problema más
omar vierte cinco litros de agua en dos
peceras derrama 200 mililitros de agua y
después divide el agua restante por
igual entre las dos peceras
2 mililitros de agua vertió omar en cada
una de las peceras así que queremos
nuestra respuesta final en mililitros
así que vamos a convertir la cantidad
original en mililitros
comenzamos con 5 litros de agua cuantos
mililitros serán nos dicen que un litro
es igual a mil mililitros así que si
tenemos cinco litros multiplicamos
nuestra cantidad por cinco así que esto
será igual a cinco veces
esta cantidad de mililitros mil por
cinco es igual a cinco mil mililitros
con esto comenzamos pero antes de que
omar divida el agua en dos peceras
derrama 200 mililitros así que a esta
cantidad le quitamos 200 mililitros y
nos queda 4 mil 800 mililitros
y esto es lo que se va a dividir entre
las dos peceras y nos preguntan cuántos
mililitros de agua vertió omar en cada
una de las peceras así que si esto se
vierte en dos peceras pues cada pecera
tendrá la mitad de esta cantidad cual es
la mitad de 4800 pues es igual a 2.400
mililitros
esto es lo que omar va a vertir en cada
una de las peceras